why you should eat over ripe bananas a
yellow skin banana with dark spots on it
it is eight times more effective in
enhancing the properties of white blood
cells
than green skin
then then bro what am i reading
something wrong what is happening here
hey guys we've covered medical memes
before we've reacted to medical dramas
but it never hit me to talk about some
of the crazy instagram posts that have
to do with health i've seen a lot of
those you've sent me them so i thought
i'd react to some of them i feel like
we're gonna be in for a stressful video
maybe a fun video a fun stressful video
i don't know let's find out
oh my god i'm just gonna read this as is
because i feel like i'm in the twilight
zone a yellow skin banana with dark
spots on it is eight times more
effective in enhancing the properties of
white blood cells than then green skin
version eating one two bananas a day
increases immunity
that was just so stressful to read i
feel like whatever health benefit you
get by eating a banana it was fully
negated by reading this meme slash
instagram post can people eat bananas
and help their immune system help
support their immune system boosting and
over boosting your immune system is
actually a really bad thing autoimmune
conditions like psoriasis crohn's
disease of the intestines that cause
really bad problems for people is an
over-boosted immune system that starts
attacking things that are not actually a
threat to you did you know once a week
for 20 minutes first of all this is a
very lavish bathtub because there's
clouds or marshmallows plus sticks
and she doesn't quite fit in it once a
week for 20 minutes sit in a hot tub
that contains a handful of epsom salts
10 drops of lavender essential oil and a
half cup of baking soda this combo draws
out toxins lowers stress and balances
your ph levels
serenity now the essential oil community
is trying to get me
frustrated it does not balance your ph
levels can you imagine if
your ph level is so tightly controlled
like between
7.35 and 7.45 is it's like little range
that it lives in and if it
comes out of that even slightly like if
it goes to 6.9 you die can you imagine
in order to live
you needed to take a bath that looks
like this
that's a problem folks you are not a
dish like if i was trying to balance the
ph levels of my chicken in a pot
maybe i'd want to throw some lemon
followed by baking soda on it but you my
friend are not a piece of chicken in a
pot
[Music]
good source or protein
is it a good source or is it a protein
we'll never know improve vitality acid
metabolism function because you know
some our metabolism function likes to
stand and we like for it to sit prevent
migraine headache lower risk of diabetes
prevent gall stones fight heart disease
next time my patient has a migraine
headache or is about to get one let's
say hey
why don't you chill out and get a cashew
can you say it's a good source i don't
know like what is considered a good
source of protein it is a source of
protein does it improve vitality what
like livelihood like how happy you are
does it acit does it assist your
metabolic function i mean anything that
you eat assists metabolic function
because your metabolism doesn't start
working does it prevent a migraine
headache that's ridiculous throw it out
there you know though i will say
something about cherries cherries have
natural aspirin in them very small
amounts
some coconut regulates thyroid function
improves brain function maintain body
mass stimulate immunity keeps heart
healthy improves digestion full of
energy glowing skin i don't know if
they're saying positive things about
coconuts or this is what's gonna happen
to you if you eat a coconut like is the
coconut full of energy does the coconut
have glowing skin is the coconut rich in
fiber kind of getting mad here maintain
body mass that's what food does folks
have you ever eaten anything before i
can put that on every label i'm pretty
sure you can put that on a pillow like
i'm pretty sure if i put this on this
bare pillow it will maintain body mass
it probably won't but anything that's
edible anything that has a calorie helps
maintain body mass so that one is
ridiculous regulates thyroid function no
you know what regulates thyroid function
thyroid stimulating hormone
it stimulates the thyroid to make
hormone you know what stimulates thyroid
stimulating hormone thyroid releasing
hormone glands baby not coconuts for
smelly underarms god i don't even know
where this is going just take a shower
that's what i'm thinking take a shower
bathe mix it's a freaking science
experiment my god just wash yourself and
you won't have smelly underarms can you
imagine if you walk into my home and you
see i'm like getting ready for a
hospital day and you see me measuring
out coconut oil and lemon juice in a
teaspoon you ask me what i'm doing and
then without any hesitation i just start
throwing it on my armpits like would you
judge me i don't know if this works
maybe i should experiment with it i
don't think i have coconut oil here or
lemon juice and their representation of
smelly underarms is like there's ribbons
coming out of her armpits and she has
red cheeks maybe she has an infection
let's talk science for a second and
leave this for a moment the reason why
our underarms actually smell bacteria
farts there's bacteria that generally
live in your armpit area and we can
fight that bacteria because when that
bacteria starts consuming little things
that are on your skin surface it starts
farting and smelling real bad but
apparently i learned something new today
lemon juice and coconut oil might try it
probably not did you know
that when it snows
[Music]
your eyes just by eating five dates in a
day helps you reduce the chances of
night blindness reduce hair loss and
risk of cancer it also helps to improve
your brain power and eyesight because it
is high in fiber and potassium i feel
like this meme is screaming at me for
some reason and this person's eye looks
like it has a cataract in it google
cataract that looks like a cataract are
people suffering like people who i
haven't had a date
i haven't eaten
i haven't consumed the food known as a
date in probably five years does that
mean i'm at a higher risk of night
blindness i think not i think that's not
how life works did you know eating one
to two figs soaked in water overnight
helps in faster weight loss as figs has
high fiber content prevent wrinkles
makes your skin soft and supple boost
immune system and promote hair growth
too figs are healthy food do they
prevent wrinkles no do they make your
skin soft and supple if your skin is not
soft and supple right now eating figs
randomly introducing them to your diet
probably won't change much man imagine
life was that simple like my skin is
rough i have two figs
now i'm supple no more unwanted facial
hair diy papaya
before
aloe vera gel after
[Music]
are they saying papaya makes you have
hair and then aloe vera gel does not
like if you're gonna make a diy you can
just put the ingredients and go diy what
do i do with do you slap the papaya on
your forehead and eat the aloe vera gel
all seriousness this looks like it would
be something targeted at females if you
are a female and you're growing facial
hair or hair in areas that you haven't
grown before and it's troubling to you
you should go speak with your family
medicine doctor if it's happening in
combination with other symptoms that can
be a sign of a problem known as pcos
there's actually a medical term for this
unwanted type of hair in a male pattern
it's called hersheytism don't be afraid
to bring that up in one of your visits i
know some patients of mine in the past
have been hesitant to bring it up but
please don't be it's something that
happens it's treatable it depends
obviously what's causing it but the
answer is not a papaya and aloe vera gel
as much as that sounds delicious it's
not the treatment doing this pose helps
to double tap oh no it helps to get rid
of double chin it increases the
flexibility of the neck provide a gentle
massage to belly organs this looks like
just basic yoga cat cow that's fine i
love cat cow i recommend it to my
patients i do it myself i do it in bed
in the morning when i wake up but why is
there a giant virus looking bubble on
this lady's back when she's doing
cow or cat is that a cow no cats do this
thing or cats nope
the cows round their back does it help
to get rid of double chin i would say no
double chin can come from i guess a few
factors one is being obese you're gonna
have more fat here you're gonna create
the appearance of a double chin if you
have bad posture i guess you could have
it too but doing this alone won't solve
that issue so i'm not a fan of it two
increases flexibility of the neck i
think it increases flexibility of the
spine and increases range of motion so
i'm with that one they went neck i'll
say spine same thing provide a gentle
massage to belly organs do you want to
massage your belly organs you know the
only organs you might want to massage
would be your intestines there's
actually certain ways that we can
activate your intestines so if you're
like backed up there are certain
massages that can help also prenatal
massages but massaging like your liver
i've never heard for that to be
effective in any sort of way oh it's not
your liver your stomach your gallbladder
we'll massage not bladder nice
click here for my most recent video on
memes it's absolutely hilarious or check
out an older video on how to not get
sick i think it's more applicable now
than ever which one you cooking stay
happy and healthy
[Music]